marty schottenheimer long-time nfl
assistant coach and a head coach with
multiple franchises passed away monday
seven
chargers browns chiefs washington one
year in washington where daniel snyder
had overcome his nature and handed the
keys to marty schottenheimer and after
one year snyder decided to take him back
and just show you how accomplished shot
and heimer was he landed with the
chargers the very next year he didn't
sit back and collect his his buy out he
he just kept working and his last
stint with the chargers was a 14-2
season in 2006. they had the game one
remember that was it marlon mccree was
it marlon mccree who fumbled the ball
after an interception opening the door
for the patriots to steal that game and
then and then uh schottenheimer was
fired he had that that ongoing feud with
aj smith the gm of the team you got to
have a gm and a coach who get along and
when you have a coach like marty
schottenheimer you got to find a way to
make it work because that team
was uh very very close to being at the
elite in the nfl and frankly if they had
beaten the patriots that day they always
matched up really well with the colts it
could have been the chargers against the
bears in super bowl 41 shireen not the
colts against the bears
and you think about all those great
coaches mike who never won a
championship it's like the players we
talk about but don coryell bud grant
marv levy paul brown dan reeves marty
schottenheimer you put all those guys
together as some of the greatest coaches
in nfl history and yet they were never
able to to win a super bowl and uh it's
unfortunate that they that he never got
one of those i think he deserved to have
won five and 13
unfortunately in the postseason for him
but what a great head coach it was and i
think it tells you how good he was
because he kept getting those head
coaching jobs right if you're lousy at
your job you don't keep getting other
jobs when you get fired
and he was different from and the two
guys who always come to mind for me are
norv turner and wade phillips greatest
coordinators yeah never really all that
great as head coaches but so good when
they went back to being coordinators
they kept getting opportunities sean
hammer's always good as a coach he was
always good it just it just worked out
the way that it did that he ended up
coaching four different teams and who
knows what would have happened in
washington if daniel snyder hadn't taken
back the keys to the car because that's
what it was it was snyder realizing
after a couple of years that maybe
things would work better if he just got
out of the way and after one year he
couldn't do it period and my favorite
marty schottenheimer story comes from
that year in washington and then the
next year with the chargers because deon
sanders had arrived in washington in
2000
and when schottenheimer became the coach
and this was a hard-nosed oklahoma
drills bull in the ring the old school
coach dion sanders didn't want anything
to do with it so sanders retired
remember he went to play for like the
toronto argonauts or one of the cfl
teams at one point he was done he's out
and they worked out a deal where he was
able to retire and he had to stay
retired and he was going to get to keep
his signing bonus money instead of
having to pay it back this was just a
year after barry sanders had to pay back
a bunch of money in the lions washington
let him keep the money but he had to
retire so the next year
when shot and hummers with the chargers
and the raiders are putting together a
super bowl team and dion decides he
wants to come out of retirement and i'm
gonna go jump on this raiders bandwagon
and daniel schneider
did him a favor released him from the
reserve retired list well there was a
glitch and it was when i first became
aware of the rule
after the trade deadline
every player who is released in any way
shape or form no matter the amount of
experience has to pass through waivers
enter marty schottenheimer and the san
diego chargers claiming dion on waivers
and preventing him from going to the
raiders and some were saying when i
pointed out today it was petty no it
wasn't petty it was fair because deon
sanders walked away from washington kept
his bonus money and now he wanted to
walk right back in and go pick the horse
that he thought was going to win and
marty and the chargers kept it from
happening i loved it then and i love it
now
my favorite mic besides that one is
before that first browns broncos afc
title game shottenheimer gave a famous
speech
called the gleam g-l-e-a-m pregame
speech and he said there's a gleam man
there's a gleam let's get the gleam and
players didn't really know what that
meant at the time they're like okay
let's get the gleam and it became a
rallying cry both for the city and for
him and he later explained that when you
see the vince lombardi trophy it has a
gleam to it and let's go get the gleam
so you've seen a lot of players today i
saw sean merriman did it did a hashtag
lean that's what it's about go get that
glee man and unfortunately he's one of
the guys who didn't get the gleam
and one of the realities in the nfl with
32 teams and there's only one gleam
every year
and when you have the patriots hogging
so many of them over a 20-year period
and you have tom brady wherever he goes
now in position to keep taking them it
makes it hard for quarterbacks it makes
it hard for the coaches but there's no
shame in 200 career victories eighth all
time on the head coaching win list four
different teams that marty
schottenheimer led during his time in
the nfl 2004 nfl coach of the year uh
great great man great great coach and we
extend our condolences obviously too
all of his colleagues his family his
friends and he's got a legacy that that
will be part of the nfl lore for years
to come
regardless of the fact that he never did
actually get the gleam sharing
mardi ball was famed
and serene
in his 21 years of coaching mike he had
two losing seasons that's my favorite
marty schottenheimer stat
that is amazing it is amazing and it is
a damn shame that it never worked out
but it just shows you how hard it is to
make that path all the way to the top of
the mountain and just because you get
close to it or get there one year there
is no guarantee you're ever going to be
back there again or even within shouting
distance of it but that doesn't mean
you're not a great accomplished coach
and that's exactly what marty
schottenheimer was just look around
twitter today and see the outpouring of
love and memories and stories about
marty schottenheimer that's it for
today's pftpm we'll see you back here
again tomorrow afternoon at five eastern
have a great evening
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports